I I've got to now talk about something
that I never thought I'd talk about is
gonna be a long winded lead-up to a
question I've been pointing out on this
program 18 USC 793 miss handling
classified information the Espionage Act
of destroying it by the way it would
apply to a lot of people I've talked
about if if I was subpoenaed but from
all my emails i deleted 33,000 and then
i asked to quash my hard drive nobody
heard of bleach bit until Hillary
Clinton and bleach pit and then had an
aide bust up all my devices like she had
happen I never heard of an exoneration
being written in May before you
interview 17 key witnesses and the main
person Hillary Clinton in July the
person that does the interview hates the
opponent of Hillary Clinton then they
exonerate her for I believe obvious
felonies right then they talk about
Russia collusion Hillary Clinton and the
DNC funneled money through a law firm
Perkins cuy and unbelievable to me a
foreign national who he's heard wasn't
supposed to be involved in in our
elections Christopher steel gets Russian
sources the FBI never verifies it they
presented to a FISA Court to spy on an
American citizen a trump campaign
associate weeks before an election they
never verified they never corroborated
and they never told those judge in the
original application three subsequent
applications that Hillary paid for and
they never verified it mr. mayor
war laws broken let's start with Hillary
did she ask I've been on look we go back
three years with this Sean when I
produced my chart
well I remember 13 crimes she committed
yeah when we got up to about 18
I'm sorry Hillary I know you're very
disappointed to win that you're a
criminal
equal justice would mean you should go
to jail
the no I do not know why the Justice
Department is not investigating you the
James Comey they probably fixed the
whole casing it was rigged
well you can't read that stupid report
that he wrote which is at the beginning
of his destruction in which he he says
we're not gonna
you know reasonable prosecutor would
indict her no honest reasonable
prosecutor wouldn't indict her he said
today or yesterday call me he said
Hilary deeply respects the rule of law
Comey said that Wow well this is a very
perverted man I feel so sorry do we have
a two-tier justice system in America
yeah we have one for Hillary and and and
and all that all those all those
Democrats Bill Clinton is equal justice
under the law at risk you and I have
talked about this I am very afraid not
just for our president over our country
there's gonna be a witch-hunt against
Republicans you you had the man on who's
lost all his money for what reason he
didn't do anything wrong the President
of the United States didn't do anything
wrong we are lucky that we have a
president who can focus in a way it
almost hurts him because they feel they
can do anything to him and he's gonna
remain focused on North Korea Iran what
do we do with China how do we help
Israel what do we do about taxes the
economy has an incredible story the
media never focuses on it I actually had
to write this down if we have the
Hillary standard the interview would
never be under oath the would never be
recorded never be transcribed and by all
the witnesses that are favorable to them
it would be in the room immunized oh and
Jared he'd be immunized going to be
immune right we'd write the exoneration
before the interview that we would agree
to destroy incriminating digital
evidence like they did in the case of
Cheryl Mills and and Hillary and and
either you or Rush Limbaugh would do the
interview rush and I would not object
well mark levin i don't think yeah
there's all that it was a political
report today basically suggesting muller
would now consider Ivanka Trump a a
target the
look look look at whole pics is one
example come on I paid more in lawyers
and she was ever paid hope hope is I
wish the American people could get to
know her hope is one of the nicest human
beings you're ever gonna meet yes she's
very loyal to Donald Trump but I I think
the president would say this she could
stand up to him when she had to what
they did to her is outrage absolutely
outrageous Ivanka Trump I would I think
I would get on get on my charger and go
right into the partners their offices
with a Lance if they go after Ivanka I
this point sir I honestly agree with you
I fear for the country let me go through
I think if they do do Ivanka which I
doubt they will it's the whole country
of turn on they're going after his
daughter what about his son-in-law they
talked about him I guess I Gerald is a
fine man you know that but men are you
know disposable but a fine woman like
Ivanka come on Andrew let's go through
the different issues that we have
brought up and spoke almost exclusively
about on this show for example you
mentioned Hillary Clinton she obviously
committed felonies we know what they are
you've identified them I believe as you
do Comey rig that Comey look at Peter
struck and Paige the they hate the dot
that president they hated the candidate
they talked about an insurance policy or
Andrew McCabe lying under oath James
Comey leaking for the purpose of getting
a special counsel also call me and
McCabe contradicting each other which is
the one has to be one of them has to be
lying I mean I actually think commis
lying
I think Comey is a big liar the McCabe
McCain is that McCabe is that have a
situational liar he's a much bigger so
if this were an equal system of justice
they'd all be prosecuted let me ask you
cuz this is my biggest regret I'm sorry
Jeff to say this but it will offer eight
a job yeah it's my biggest regret in not
having taken that job I wanted to be
sick my biggest regret and I like Jeff
Sessions but he never should have
recused himself well
never never should have appointed
Rosenstein I've never heard of somebody
being appointed or confirmed and
recusing do you know that Rosenstein
with Whitmore the night or the day he
was interviewed by President Trump to be
FBI director walked out knew that he was
turned down and then appointed in the
next day is there are did you know rod
Rosen seen apparently according to
reports that we'd have it on this
program signed off on one of the FISA
extensions the one with the unverified
dossier is the bulk of information as
the as the Grassley grant memo said that
he personally signed off does that not
conflict him out of all of this how
about he's also a witness it's a
critical information for a Justice
Department that pontificates I told you
the only crimes committed here by the
government let me ask you about them
Andrew McCabe said without the dossier
there wouldn't have been a FISA
application I would ask you doesn't the
FBI according to FISA a law you're very
familiar with an FBI protocol mandate
that they verify corroborate what they
present to a FISA judge isn't that
mandatory
wouldn't it be mandatory to identify
that the dossier was created by an
opposition party candidate and not as a
political asterisk absolutely is that a
crime yeah yes obstruction of justice
invasion of people's privacy on no basis
at all it's a civil rights violation
unreasonable search and seizure it's a
civil rights violation if they searched
it with me based on that we'd sold for a
civil rights violation this is a Justice
Department completely unhinged and out
of control
it breaks my heart Sean I devoted most
of my life to the Justice Department
I work for great attorney attorneys
general my friend Michael Mukasey was
one of the greatest and I watched it
with great ad partner's my partner great
admiration for Michael to watch this
happen under a man that I loved Jeff
Sessions I just feel bad and I know the
president was heartbroken over this it
isn't that he's angry he thought
profit but he never expected this from
Jeff the two of them can redeem
themselves sessions and Rosenstein they
should order the investigation over I
don't think that's gonna happen well I
don't think it's gonna happen either but
if they understood justice Jackson's
admonition to prosecutors that I always
live by which we're not supposed to get
convictions were supposed to do justice
let me stay focused on this FISA issue
for just a second but as rod Rosenstein
Oh after they had subpoenaed the
documents went into Paul Ryan's office
begging him not to release it we never
would have had the new Nest memo or the
Grassley gram memo that said the bulk of
the the application was the the dossier
Hillary paid for so my question is this
not only that there were three
subsequent renewals with the same false
information it's the same lying by
omission if you will by not telling the
FISA judges that it was a that Hillary
paid for it if I stand up in court at
some point in the next three or four
months well I really like to be and I
recite these facts I think the judge is
gonna look at me and say I don't believe
that's true how could the Justice
Department have gone so far away from
the fair and honest administration of
justice under decent people but I think
the pressures on them was so great they
just caved in and I once again I say
it's one way to redeem themselves get
control of this this remember senator
Stevens case sure oh yeah he lost an
election and then the judge overturned
at all because they withheld exculpatory
a government misconduct that's correct
well there's been more government
misconduct in this case then there has
been conduct are you concerned this was
supposed to be about the Trump campaign
Russia collusion gone it's gone okay
never happened he's been cleared is that
my question is are you concerned in the
process of this we did discover that a
foreign national
Christopher steel was paid through
fusion GPS use Russian sources that not
only weren't verified turned with
debunked
are you concerned that that was paid for
to manipulate the American people in the
lead-up to an election isn't that closer
to the mandate than Michael Cohen why
isn't that happening somewhere smaller
on that sir have it having having
something to do with paying some stormy
Daniels woman 130,000 I mean which is
gonna turn out to be perfectly legal
that money was not campaign money sorry
I'm giving you a fact now that you don't
know it's not campaign money no campaign
finance violation so they funneled it
through the law firm frontal over him
and the president repaid it oh I didn't
know that he did yeah there's no
campaign finance law zero so the
president like every Shan so what this
decision was made by everybody everybody
was nervous about this from the very
beginning I wasn't I knew how much money
Donald Trump put into that campaign I
said a hundred thirty thousand ain't
gonna do a couple of checks four hundred
and thirty thousand when I heard Cohen's
retained or thirty five thousand when he
was doing no work for the president mmm
I said that's how it was repaying that's
how he's repaying it with a little
profit and a little margin foot paying
taxes for Michael the Flores do you know
the president didn't know about this I
believe that he did I know about the
specifics of it as far as I know but he
did know about the general arrangement
that Michael would take care of things
like this like I take care of things
like this for my clients I don't burden
them with every single thing that comes
along these are busy people what did you
think of the rain on his office one of
the reasons we would hesitate to
cooperate any further and I think this
is what the breakdown with with Dowd
during during back in January that took
them by surprise that's beyond anything
that is an outrageous violation of
attorney-client privilege
beyond Donald Trump's attorney-client
privilege a lot of innocent people I
gave him 10 bucks 20 how about innocent
people like right we got to continue who
calls you that night I'll talk to you
about that